[Music]
so
the italian mafia oh
has just decided to open their doors to
gay men finalist time ever wow diversity
pretty [ __ ] inclusive emerge
that the mob boss's son
is a drag queen
which gang which one uh just they're
saying that uh is it in italy
or in america italy oh they're diverse
they're more progressive out there huh
because i heard the american italians
way more traditional than the italian
italians really the ones that are run by
robert de niro no because i saw it on a
yeah like that style i saw it on the
episode of sopranos which is a very
legitimate that is a really legitimate
source the sopranos it's a really
legitimate they don't like calzones on
sopranos
it's a very don't bring up calzones
brother look into italian-american
culture and there was this one very very
deep episode where the italian mafia in
the us and new jersey went to meet the
italian mafia in italy and the whole
time you know they were feeling judged
by the other guys they're calling them
peasants because they like tomato sauce
on their spaghetti and it was just a
really good like cultural observation is
marinary not good
marinara is not classy and they were
calling them peasants what about classic
marinara they don't even use it it's
like white sauce you know or whatever it
is
it's not even the one that we used i
don't know what it was and then and then
they saw that the italian mafia out
there was doing things that they would
never do in america like punk kids on
the street and all this stuff and then
they're just like you know the american
mafia we're honorable guys you know i
heard the italian mafia is hardcore as
[ __ ] like they're basically like you
know if you don't have like prego in the
glass jar
they go because like you know how you
can have it in the plastic yeah yeah
yeah they don't [ __ ] around huh they're
like yo if it's if it's in the plastic
we're gonna you're gonna [ __ ] around
with that fake parmigiano as well you
know yeah you're gonna be in plastic if
you have the one in the plastic but you
have to have the glass jar the og tub of
it yeah and then you get to be in glass
yeah and then you're fine because that's
how grandma made it
that's how grandma bought it he can't be
that happy how do they find out the mob
bosses uh kid is a drag queen yeah so um
well first let me just tell you real
quick is that them getting soft too
because i think like maybe 50 years ago
if someone's son had like had a drag
queen son they just smoked his ass right
that's the most thing i've ever heard
about what if the drag queen is also
smoking people yeah oh he's a productive
he's like a murdering dragon he's a
productive maid man
like he's a tough [ __ ] i would
assume it's probably just like closeted
back then a little bit more so yeah
homosexual is homosexuality is still
taboo among the older bosses
um the mafia has however relaxed their
rules to prevent gay men in their lower
ranks as long as they don't parade it in
public so in the lower ranks as well is
pretty uh brady though can you still be
a maid man though boss what's that thing
if you could still be a maid man or not
yeah you just got a murder [ __ ]
it could be a made queen
you could drag bodies
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
i wonder what a drag queen mobster looks
like i'm just trying to picture this it
doesn't work unfortunately it's not a
picture lame
worse mom is still pretty private he
probably does that at work he probably
dresses like laura croft i'm thinking
why laura croft that's a sick idea still
pixelated boobs do you guys miss the
titties they took her titties away i
don't get why they took the big titties
away i wasn't really paying attention
can i be like honestly really yes what
are you talking about
like no like what was the last lure game
you played
i didn't play the game i was just
beating it all the way to the videos
you were just walking by the [ __ ] just
beating it all the way who plays people
play the game apparently that's where
you see the titties right
i don't know i play the quick time
action if you know what i mean
the the very old one
the very old one you could you get her
to crawl and then you pause it so you
could jack off
i get it i don't know about that i get a
crawl under the water you know i really
didn't like the new tomb raider movie
with the wish of the candor yes
yes it was not the angelina jolie glory
it wasn't as bouncy i found
the way they shot it i think
less bounce
must've been using like a steady cam
it's hard to top angelina jolie though
what about her tops
it's hard to it's hard it is during that
time i don't know who else could
pass her sexiness like who would who
would be an equivalent of this date of
her if you have to do laura grant for
tomb raider god that's such a hard
question oh what's her name what's her
name from a true detective she was hot
he's probably not even a woman it's
probably like brett man rock or
something
[Laughter]
like that's the
equivalent because he's smoking yeah
he's fine what's her name anna de armas
no not even though that is she was she
was in the [ __ ] reason uh james james
band movie what the [ __ ] is the arnold
barmus she was the chick in the dress
very expressive face chick in the dress
yeah she was like rolling around [ __ ]
killing everybody what movie is this she
wasn't exactly bouncing around no time
to die okay so we want more bouncy but
not more but robbie she's too blonde
someone's sporty like uh yeah scar
she had a good little plump to her
movements who's jiggling all the [ __ ]
very jiggly better than scar joe she
literally got this gave him the soul
stone jiggling all over them
falling off the goddamn mountain wait
who's who's even jiggly nowadays no but
when she hit the ground she's [ __ ]
jiggling all over the [ __ ] place
jiggly's not in right now that's crazy i
think they're all on tick tock
no it's not on hollywood the chick from
the chick from true detective oh she was
in baywatch as well well i like baywatch
anderson no no the new baywatch uh
something somebody's real
yes alexandria something but she's who
is she she's close she's close huh who
is she in true detective she's bouncing
all over the phone oh she's the one
that's married to [ __ ] woody
harrelson right or she was like digging
woody harrelson alexandra
d'addario
yeah she don't look like a tomb raider
to me she does it sporty bruh dyer hair
brown you [ __ ] idiot she doesn't look
sporty she doesn't oh she's not
supporting she's in baywatch [ __ ]
jiggling bouncing yeah dude she's
[ __ ] bouncing out of that tower
i mean i mean maybe not the best angle
she was like double dribbling all over
the place
[Laughter]
they're sick you guys are sick [ __ ] the
harlem [ __ ] globetrotters
well who else did not like olivia wilde
i like living a while because it looked
like not super bouncy jiggly but like
very
talented look i'll put it like this i'm
not hearing like
wow
with olivia wilde on screen that's all
i'm saying
that's true in the recent years there's
been a reduction of bounce
a lot it was a huge reduction yeah
didn't the whole uh the kim kardashian
no longer have a brazilian butt lift
thing become the whole meme no longer
however she got rid of it yeah i think
so she red she reduced it yeah it's like
it's regular now because like it was
getting kind of insane like the whole
family or some [ __ ] she took the shelf
out of there yeah less ducky now more
ashamed dude she got diaper bugs she's
about to put books on that thing she put
a whole glass on it you could put a
[ __ ] two-hour candle on that thing
man you know they gotta change up lara
croft tomb raider and they gotta make it
like cardi b or something you know just
really throw the energy into a totally
different realm and then you're like
this is reinvented and maybe i'm down
for like that's like a really gross
laura croft just
a different kind of bouncy result she's
all raunchy that's what i mean
like a walmart warcroft no like a cardi
b one well cardi b oh that was more like
i guess that was more like a make the
stallion thing but like yeah it's like
he just
dude nicki minaj though
that's like throwing a bowling ball on a
[ __ ] water bed
that's a jiggle
yeah dude why do they why did i call
this show toxic i don't get it it's not
toxic at all not toxic at all these are
real opinions this is just how this is
like men formulating opinions and
beliefs i feel like we're putting people
up and i feel like a lot of people would
agree with us i think they do yeah and
it was a very diverse group of beauties
that we talked about as well we just
pitched a dario for the new tomb raider
she might not have even been in the
[ __ ] castle we want her to get a job
she's not working right now it's crazy
she's not working right now that's a
pity by the way when we submit for
streamies this video yeah this is the
one that's the one that you want playing
is the little snippet this is the one
we're going to win for like we lift
people up
that's the one we're going to win better
than that better than clapping for women
for 15 minutes that was good that was
really good classic video that's just
art to me oh that or the lizard gang
gangbang video but i think we're gonna
win yeah yeah we gotta find the lizard
gangbang video i think we're gonna win
is what i'm saying i don't know where
that video's at it's gonna cut to our
faces like eagerly awaiting the crowd
just like i can't we're up for it we
have a running chance just getting news
for a lizard gangbang and we're like yes
oh no the worst thing is like it's like
it's they they announce all the nominees
and [ __ ] and then we all start standing
up and then and then they announce it's
like it's like dude perfect we're like
we're already standing up we have to go
sit back down you're like halfway to the
stage we're [ __ ] we're hugging each
other in the aisle
we're like we got tears in our eyes
oh my god i'm leaving we're rolling out
speeches we [ __ ] do it
like first of all thank you i want to
thank my mom
[Laughter]
those are the only two women who will
claim the show
do
[Music]